[Music]
hi how's it going
hope you're having a good day so today I
wanted to show you a little bit about
some of the games that I had and I kind
of just one or ended up in the draw
mainly because of my power of bluffing
so I thought that's kind of interesting
kind of cool to show so that is the idea
for today and I can't just want to jump
into it because I want to be able to
show you as many games as possible
alright so let's jump in so this is a
game that I had between omerta mochel
and myself in 2015 Abu Dhabi tournaments
I think she is sugar sauce wife so that
was kind of interesting because I played
them both I think in different years but
well those kind of the same tournaments
so that's is a little bit of story
background so II 45 we got to this
lovely transposed Italian line and so
for those of you who watch our twitch
channel we've been playing this line a
lot like a lot a lot and it's beginning
to get a little too repetitive so we can
we're trying to I was trying to come up
with something new for this specific
game as well because I wanted it to be a
little bit more than just so after
Bishop before she played Bishop d2 I
didn't want to just whoops not that
Bishop I didn't want to just take take
and do this d5 because this doesn't
really have much for black and since I
was a high rated I was hoping for a
little bit more excitement out of the
opening
compared to well this so that is why I
actually played this Knight takes e4 and
after Bishop before night before Queen
b3 sorry
queen bee tree is a bat isn't the best
idea
just because now I have d5 and lift take
take and now I'm also castling if take
and I have this Bishop I have an
isolated plan to go after now I actually
prefer black so let's go back to the
line I wanted to talk about ah
the bishop f7 check king of seven queen
b3 b5 now my first question for you guys
have you do you guys play this anybody
here plays this white black do you feel
comfortable in this position
I'd like to know a little bit more about
what you guys is really play so I can
feel a little bit connected because all
right so we have someone who plays this
with black nice so it's a good idea to
have this game this position so yeah you
don't like the king hold on you're gonna
love this move 95 check what do you
think you should do with your King hints
if you've been watching our twitch
channel you already know the answer to
this game to this position so you're on
the check what do you want to do with
your King
you don't really have many option King
up six that's really the king you have
six stars like Queen f3 and that's gonna
help light a little bit like king of six
I can just play sorry
I meant after II I don't know why I keep
miss speaking about moves now if you
move this night I can easily return pick
this up and the King is not really ideal
here so your choices here are between a
six or g8 in the game I chose King g8
but a king g6 actually is better like
surprisingly because if you take on
before I have c5 attacking your pawn
attacking your your knight and if your
Queen goes to for example a three we
pick this guy up I had in one of the
online games we had Queen b3 happen and
Queen 85 should have been and now black
is actually much better because what do
you want to do with your king you can't
play 92 because I take it if you play
Knight c3 there's take over here and
then this guy is on track so yeah that's
another problem that's why it has to
deal with so you have to be very
specific about Queen a tree I think when
b5 is also possible but Queen a tree is
stronger so clean a tree take over here
and this is a playable position like
f4 as possible and then after f4 I think
we can simply just play something like
Queen f8 or Queen d6 and try and 6
change these guys off I can't like the
idea of queen of 8 going for the
exchange Mike you can Castle I can take
over there take that just Bishop d7 I
mean I'm not saying this is like the
safest King ever but I think this is a
very playable position for both sides so
that is like a little trick with King e6
that is possible and then followed by c5
so however in the game I was really
afraid to play King e6 so I just
King 3:8 after King g8 now my opponent
started to actually get a little too
good
like Queen takes before I went to Queen
g5 trying to create some sort of an
attack like if you castle maybe I can
push away free stuff like that power
fluff right so after Queen g5 what do
you think it's White's best move
so white to move what do you think
should happen
develop tonight I think that was pretty
thing no g-trainer I can just play
Bishop h3 you can think a little bit
more about intermediate news they see an
intermediate moves cast on there is
Bishop h3 hmm H Street I can just pick
on G two guys make sure you think about
your opponent moves yes Queen b3 yeah
claim Beecher is the best move because
you are doing intermediate you're
attacking this guy and you're all
defending this h3 square so now you want
to castle so now it's black to move
what should we do we should defend the
pawn right I thought about c6 honestly
but I wasn't really sure if c6 is the
right way to go and I really wanted to
develop my pieces so I just went with
Bishop e6 Castle Rock f8 now my biggest
hope is to like start pushing this pawn
so roof f8 now why to move do you think
this is a this is a good position do you
think white can start developing the
knight on c3
you'll be nice out gotta be careful
though there's 92 so do you think 92 is
playable as it's worth it for black to
try and go after material
so let me ask my question another way
let's say white boy is Knight c3 now
what do you want to do be careful bishop
is true you'll get Queen d5 then ouch
so now my question is nice c3 do you
want to play ninety two if not then what
else do you want to do
so that's the whole thing do you think
this fork is actually good for white or
black so right now as well acting for
white people 893 and we were thinking
about if 92 is a good move or not
so you want to find 92 yeah I don't
think night I mean I don't honestly
think there is anything better than 92
here and that's the problem like if you
take I will just take Quincy's 623 and
now you gotta play like c6 and this is a
bad Bishop this is a good night
it doesn't really it's a it's not very
ideal for black so that's why we would
think about instead of Knight takes c3
Knight d2 so 92 what do you think is
White's best move probably take on b7
right you gotta eat the pawns let's say
we take on f1 take it back now black to
move what do you want to do
maybe but I'm not really sure about so
we have Queen d2 we have a tribe but so
much three guys please be careful which
I was three or d5 pawn and then we
regret losing one basically like two
moves so careful with that
yeah I think h5 is actually the best
chance for a cast and that's actually
what I played in the game tonight takes
d5 and at this point I wasn't sure if I
should take this or not my other option
was to play Turkish six to open up some
breathing room for the King and keep
pushing but I didn't really know what to
do after Knight takes T 7 because this
just looks so scary what am I gonna do
after it's like it's this pawn is like
already passed pawn and we this is a
move like what 18 yeah this is really
this was a really scary situation so I
didn't really want to like gets to get
the Jake drown in it basically like yeah
there's there are still things to do but
like I'm losing basically out of my
palms so I kind of want to keep my pawns
please can i play Bishop h3 here
I mean if Bishop h3 just Knight e3 stops
everything also I can just take on c7
and the Queen is defending this so I
mean it's possible but it doesn't really
serve any purpose and you're just losing
more material so that's why I would just
I just took on d5 take back and now King
h7 so white foot is Queen d7 and at this
point I was like okay let's face it my
position is pretty horrible I have very
little counter play but one of the
things I could do is I could try and
trick white into still going after these
pawns and it would allow me to develop
and go for the back rank because the
back rank is pretty weak right now right
so that was basically the only idea I
had so now my question to you black to
move how can you execute that plan
Nicaea Queen d2 is here at pH so another
question do you think your position as
black would be better if the Queen's are
off the board are still on the board
would you have more chances then
so if you think the position would be
better with Queens off the board then
that should automatically give you few
moves to think about now
Brook after just no guys don't shoot
that moves
repite is just a horrible mistake I just
take it back with the rook at least
check and just recap one guys you can do
better
alright so instead of rook F - yes Queen
a5 is the move I was referring to c5 is
another move to think about but if
Knight have seven now I don't like I'm
in real pickle like take take yes you
can take over here but now white is just
more pawns in an ending I can't even
just go for Queen e7 and it's just
getting a little sad so in order to keep
my pieces on the board is queen of five
system so if take this is actually a
good idea for black because now this is
what one two three four pawns to four so
it's basically a knight and two pawns to
a rook right so it's not the end of the
world actually this is interesting like
f4 I just put it drifts to d8 and well
actually not can you defend this okay
fine I'll pick this up 933 you'll pick
this up if not f4 let's save any fruity
one just rip over here and I'm picking
this up you move it there c5 now I got a
pass pound myself so this is a very I
mean what is kind of getting a little
sad so that is why Queen a5 is a good
idea what is the problem with Queen d8 I
don't think when d8 is bad but if Queen
d8 what if white just plays Queen -
sneaking h3 but maybe even take take and
97 yeah I think this is the easiest way
to go for white and this is now this
endgame this rock endgame
yeah just rip is active but doesn't
necessarily mean much
so Queen if you're gonna exchange the
Queen's try to keep it all activated so
Queen a5 and the game she just took my
pawn and it gave me some chances to
activate my pieces we want to drug c8
she took on a seven and now Rick f8 so
um you can see that this is coming up
right and actually this position is
right now kind of close to equal well I
don't think equal is the right way to
say it this position has enough counter
play for black to be able to pull
something out like best move right now
is Knight f3 Knight f3 we play like rook
e8 gotta move this Queen where to go
maybe like Queen c7 now we start eating
the pawns so yeah and I was just
basically bluffing right now I wasn't
like I mean it's a threat but well it's
also a bluff because it's easily you can
easily stop it
so she actually blundered and she played
Queen a3 which resulted in just going up
to so yeah this is the first game I
wanted to show you the power of bluff
the second I mean it was kind of more
interesting honestly let me run a new
one alright I think that's about it let
me go back yeah so this game was in
again 2015 maybe like a week or two
after the game that I just showed you
this one was in phantom a disc bulge in
years 2015 I didn't think this was like
the second or third round game for a
second yeah I was playing with a French
girl that last night is kind of hard to
pronounce but first I was Andrea
Christina last time I saw Shuster white
Jess who's doing good and so this is a
very interesting game because of again
the power off honestly but let me show
you so
Norman Inge normal Sicilian con so far
everything normal we're getting pieces
out I'm still not strong if I want short
caster a long cast all end up going for
short cast these are this was
preparation so far and like I had a
general general idea what I was looking
for in the opening and in the middle
game like where my pieces belong but it
wasn't like like a deep preparation like
if you play e5 I'm gonna play this if
you play d6 I'm gonna play that it was
my buzz where my pieces belong and I
actually hear it's possible to take over
there and start regrouping pieces a
little bit maybe bring it okay do you
want or something but I really like the
idea Bishop g5 and then Bishop h4 so it
might look a little weird it does to me
and so right now the my idea was that
this is a weak square I'm going to use
that and I'm hoping that black will
allow me some ideas to move a little so
I get some ideas to attack in the
kingside the Queen side as well so those
are my basic ideas so now black/white b5
and so here why to move what do you
think white should do
some of the ideas could be move the King
push to F pawn you can say move a for it
probably 95 I think those are the
logical moves to go for yeah I do like
the idea of a for my one problem was if
I play a for B for move the knight what
if a five I didn't like this idea I
wanted to have like enough Tempe to play
a 4 B 4 a 5 so that this pawn is lonely
here that was kind of my idea
so after b5 I went with 95 in 95 now my
opponent plays King h8 I don't really
know why I assume because she was a
little scared of like c4 so King gets 8
I was like okay sure I'll play King just
want to maybe I want to play f4 so she
played d6 now what do you think is the
best move for a white to do we do have a
nice strategic idea
hmm f-for a little too early
a for yeah exactly so we want to play
this a for because as I said if not
before
well first of all this pawn is weak so
if before we can play a five and fix
this one then this pawn is weak so we
can go further keyboards and start going
after this guy maybe after you bring the
bishop this pawn will eventually fall so
after a four she took I take now a five
so after a five again why to move what
do you think why it should do
mmm fish of a six not really what is
just fish away six no never mind I was
thinking if this should be six it's a
little I don't really like it
well what if Bishop a6 just thinking
about Bishop f2 but I don't think that
we're supposed to show up - I was
thinking take take and then there's
Bishop e7 back let me show you oh not
that Bishop this Bishop this is that cuz
take take and now there's Bishop e7 yeah
Bishop e6 I don't I mean I'm not saying
this is a bad news but Bishop e6 just
feels a little out of the flow
what if I just go on 94 and talk your
queen if you take here maybe I'll just
take their first and then take that with
the bishop the best idea was actually
mentioned in the game in the chat with
rook e1 you're just this is a weak bond
you're just bringing to put more
pressure on it there is nothing wrong
with that
so after rook a1 here we have this kind
of interesting idea for black a shipwide
Bishop e7 I think our idea was pretty
clear like if you take on a5 there's 94
right that guy and this guy are under
attack so now what do you think white
should do
I do like the idea of after Bishop II
one but why not deal why shouldn't we
deal with this current problem of night
coming to d4 first because it's good
talking or clean so maybe we could just
you know relocate the Queen I do like
the idea of treat don't get me wrong so
this should be five what if what if
mmm maybe ninety seven mission field is
also interesting because you just want
to take on c6 and pick this up right so
maybe nights east seven hmm maybe now f3
to bring the bishop yeah I like this
this is cool alright let's go back a
little and yeah thank you Queen d2 after
Bishop d7 the most interesting one is
Queen d2 whoops not that I think Queen
d2 I think most interesting is actually
Queen d2 because now if Queen d2 what
can white do what can black - well I
think black would try and play something
like maybe 97 but if 97 I can just pick
that up right take even if like the same
night goes to d4 mmm maybe just put that
truck on a tree or a to take here take
that back now this is a good idea for
white what's doing good probably doing a
little too good
maybe now I can't even do this a force
or F trees yeah okay this is good
well in the game surprise surprise
instead of Queen d2 I played Bishop b5
and I was very clear I just wanted to
eat this pawn like I just I had a just
something very clear on my mind
black could play Bishop e6 but it was
still a worse position for black so now
Knight G some Knights GE 7 is actually
the best idea for black but black didn't
go for it
she played b5 sorry f5 and now I want
you guys to give me one or two moves
full moves not just half moves like what
does this black does this white is this
at least one and a half moves and so
why'd you move what do you think we
should do just 1/2 a quick so if you're
telling me take it what will black do
and how do you respond to that move
because I'm doing this not because I
think I don't just because when I'm also
teaching like on one-on-one classes I
always try to encourage the students to
make sure that he's just covering his
bases just calculating and not giving up
that's like one move so just maybe push
yourself and give me that one move like
a full move and something extra so it
becomes a habit for you instead of just
take thinking about your moves do you
cover your opponent too so yeah please
do that and all right Thank You Rosa
so yeah mmm we could do Bishop c6 Bishop
c6 roof a5 but the problem with that
would be the move f4 coming up not
necessary right now like Bishop c6
Bishop c6 and now if you play rook a5 I
was thinking something more like maybe
Bishop c5 no Bishop c5 is back we just
take that maybe it's just Bishop takes
d5 we take back and now let me add
something like f4 so that's all I was
considering I mean why does it still
better so I think Bishop Bishop c6 is
still a good idea
so yeah I think that's a good idea but
let's go back so but it's it would be
much better to just take on f5 yes also
Thank you Thank You Jacob
for giving f3 f4 idea bish of f2 is okay
but I think we should be one is even
stronger now you're actually talking
over there too this is also good for
white another line that we could think
about is yes thank you
noodle and Beltran for it takes at five
yeah it takes if I was actually the best
and that's what I went for - you gotta
take it at the root cause if you could
Bishop this guy is falling all right so
I reckon five now the best move here
would be to play Bishop d3 which I
didn't play so you guys are good don't
worry if you didn't see it
Bishop d3 is a very interesting move
because well you can't really move the
stroke like if you play rook back to f8
I can just play Queen s5 and now I'm
actually going for an attack exactly for
talking about the recoil - like h4 and
like possible ideas with that also an
interesting idea was I was shared was if
Angie fight there could be h4 entrapping
urgh which is your peer correct so let's
go back after take bishop teacher is the
strongest idea but I also kind of
slightly oops missed it I just want
Bishop c6 which is another like it's a
good move but it's just not as good like
Bishop c6 Bishop d3 would have made the
game much much easier much faster so
that we wouldn't even need to get to the
bluffing point because so far we didn't
really Bluff it just plays good news so
take take rook takes a five
and Bishop c5 let's exchange those rooks
too
now I decided to take on c5 which is a
okay move we should be 555 is the best
one because if you take on c5 now I can
just point 93 defend this defend attack
this defend that and seems to be going
well
so Bishop d5 is the best chance now why
to move what do you think white should
do and again please give me just like
why does this practice that why does
this like a full cycle of move not just
them I want to play this idea
ouch
all right
double attack on Bishop and rook so I
assume that would be Queen d3 but if
Queen t3 guys what do you think black
would do how do you think mark would
stop that if Queen goes to d3 well thank
you for sharing
well Queen d3 is the very strong the
other thing is if it doesn't work
because just Knight takes e4 so it's
best for black to play Knight eat seven
to defend this and the rook and yeah
then we can simply just move this night
away or play something like mmm I like
the idea Knight e4 I think this is a
nice idea so I think this would have
been a better version of what I played
because in the game I went with 94 first
and then I got this nasty Knight f4 and
now Knight f4 I would have I'm kind of
losing my bishop over here and now there
is also a tack getting formed against my
king this with this pieces even though
they're just few of them but something
is like opponent is basically slipping
away a little bit so gotta play fast f3
defending my knight and potentially
opening some breathing room for the king
so here she plays Queen b6 once you move
what do you think is the best move
well surprisingly Teemo after you here
was actually the best move so guys guys
you were forgetting this Bishop over
here alright good thank you
so yeah
b3 Beltran good job yeah b3 or c3 I
think these two are the good ideas
because well basically if you play b3 in
the c3 next with your playing before if
you boobs if you play b3 that is what I
play it next move you are well actually
next time I'm asking you what to do so
here let's say white to move again after
h6 now what do you want to do do you see
any way to activate your pieces better
Thank You Brazil yeah I wrote a six
Thank You markup for k-6 so the idea
behind wrote a six is fairly simple also
here it would have been a may be a
better idea to first play like 93
so after like you move the bishop away
now we could try and maybe play
something like croaky one oops nope
pretty one and then Queen III some stuff
like that but I thought this would be a
little too passive so I just went to
Drew k-6 and after rook a six wait
before I'm thinking what if coin went to
c7 we just picked this up right Knight
takes c6 Bishop takes b3 because of this
background guitar now we get check right
because if King goes up we have just
queen d3 if Bishop goes to g8 I guess
now we can just play g3 attack this
truck and I think white is doing good
der and right now like I mean it's not
like a super winning position but it's a
very desirable position okay so in the
game after locating should just played
Queen before and I took this chance to
just bring the rook back because I was a
little afraid like I don't want to take
on these snakes because there would be
trick f6 and pinning whoops where's the
rest of this error there we go
and there would be some pinning and if I
don't take over here I mean if I take
with jerk that's a blunder cuz if Bishop
b4 so I couldn't really eat this pawn so
I could have played something like 92 93
but it makes more sense to me to play
rock a4 and force the clean to go away
first before trying to improve the
position and here I made the knight c3
which isn't really the strongest idea
but I felt really stuck like I didn't
really know how time for the position
some of the potential possible ideals
were like a stream or something like
between III whoops there were some of
the ideas to try and improve the
position rookie six didn't work as of
efore taking on e4 96 doesn't work
because of your cap six and alright I
guess there's a question so Wow too fast
the wrong way alright let's just look at
this for a second
the problem is Bishop takes even if you
give this check just King age 7 and you
can't I mean if you take over if you
take it back
rook f4 and we found a one so back rank
attack well basically back crying mates
so that's kind of the big problem all
right
hope that helps the confusion here okay
for Queen b8 now I went to Knight c3 my
I was kind of hoping he would take my
work on a 4 she would take my work on a
4 and after 94 I thought this position
is actually good but it's kind of still
pretty complicated like white still has
a little bit of the advantage left just
because well being the pawn up but it's
nothing that concrete like let's say
Queen goes to before we try to maybe
open the some room for the king now
queen but centralized and what am I
supposed to do maybe c4 mmm there's
Bishop c6 this night is extremely
misplaced so let's go back to drugs not
changing so in the game she played
Bishop c6 which was kind of a relief
because now I kind of have this to palm
side pawn majority against one and I can
also I have enough Tempe to maybe bring
my queen in the center a little bit so
what I did I think queen d3 is also a
good idea but I wanted h3 just be
I wanted to open some room for my king
because every single thing that's human
she was doing there was a background
katakan whoa so just h3 let's keep that
King just have some breathing room
she went clean before now watch a move
what do you think you should do do you
think it's oh I was gonna give up the
move so let's just say Queen before why
to move what do you want to do let's go
with that
so Quincy for was the move that I
thought and I played in the game too but
it wasn't the most accurate when there
is something even better
hmm
yes Queen d3 thank you Mark
Queen d3 would be the ideal way to go
about it and so we're just wanting Queen
d3 and the chance well the idea is that
I just want to fly like king gage -
didn't just bring this night back here
and maybe go after this pawn yeah I
think that would have been like an
interesting idea
I was with Queen c4 and take take this
this King felt really hard to win right
now and that's why I'm think I'm
thinking this is like a bluff right now
because it's it doesn't feel I mean it's
not as clear like you would have to
juggle a lot to get win this game and
yeah I did - like King g8 I started to
audit the best move which is 95
attacking the palm I was a girl so if
you take this great we're gonna go to
the pennant game whoo-hoo perfect
however she played king of 796 King bee
six now what do you think he should do
with your night do you want to go to e4
do you want to go to b5 I think those
are your two safest choice mark it's one
still does will hold advantage but it's
a little rough right now so we got to up
our bluffing games so way to move what
do you want - nice c8 this feels really
off the board like whatever just walking
me five can differ and start eating your
pawns c5 King d5 alright let's let's
implement the suggestion that I did
please give me like if you say c5 make
sure to tell me what black does so c5 is
bad because of King d5 so make sure you
say that
if you think see that is bad because of
candy 5 if you think C 5 is good don't
at least give me something for black too
hmm
so 94 yes if black does take it this end
game is not so I mean way way better in
this end game you guys whenever you try
to play King if I will just play c5 and
you can't take this because I start
pushing so that's why in 94 was also
possible but the thing is if 94 probably
first takes I think g5 c5 now King g5
and I'm attacking your Knights you move
this knife let's say you go 92 now I get
King here and this King is really really
active we need to bring this guy in
so that's my biggest problem right now
this guy this King on issue 1 so I live
with Knight b5 and my idea was basically
to find the best way to activate my kink
kinky 5 now why to move how do you think
we should try and like what do you think
we should do
there's a question about 94 we'll go
back in it and look at it again let's
try and figure out what to do with white
here yeah I thinking g1 is the safest
choice yeah
so let's go back to 94 and take a look
at that
so 94 kingi 5 well if not c5 what else
do you want to do if you play King g1
now this is a kind of the problematic
endgame can you have to maybe g5 first I
mean not okay now this is winning for
white
well what if just well hold on what if I
just play King d4 though to push you to
play c5 and as soon as you play c5 now
g5 king f2 now the black is just holding
black is not eating this Knights just
holding that was a big problem that I
had in the game too because dick my King
couldn't get in and her king was just in
the center blocking all of my ideas so
what now black can't just play Bishop to
b5 or d5 let's just go over here to take
this square away too and that's that's
the biggest problem this King can't get
in like you a king he won all right it's
okay I'll just hold so that's that's
that's actually the reason we need to
Bluff this game a little bit so all
right nice effort as possible I just
thought Knights b5 might give me more
bluffing chances so 95 King g5 and now
we did we agreed on Kingi 1g5 let's
bring in the king and now why to move
what do you think you should do
each one no not really because if you
play h4 I mean opponents can just take
and that's not really ideal well what's
your next move because now you're kingís
has to stay here you well yeah you want
to mess up the structure ee I get that
but it's not really good because your
King can't get in your Knights can't
really come back here your pawns are
stuck and not saying this is losing for
wise but I am saying that it doesn't
help your position um something else
does we could think about is well right
now black has to pound on right
but black is actually holding pretty
decently actually black is kind of
paralyzing White's ideas a lot too
so maybe it's best to try and figure out
the way to try and trick upon them
because if you play h4 you're basically
waving white flag like all right I don't
have any other plan as my king is just
gonna stay here my nights just gonna
stay there might as well just offer a
draw at this point so that is why we
don't really want to do this h4 but we
do want to try and keep this King team
so c3 I think it would be a good idea
for black to play each word here
because black isn't really pushing for a
win black is just pushing for white to
run out of booze and we're in make a
mistake or do a repetition so I think h4
would have been what kind of a good idea
here maybe 94 94 bishop eh now we can
maybe try and bring the king a little
bit
[Music]
going here it's gonna be check o king d3
Bishop g6 King ashore all right now it's
good got good
so that's the whole idea we're trying to
bluff to go off opponents into once you
go eat the pond or just getting away
from the center so the you are king can
get activated so that's not it's like
one possible scenario to run all right
so um after I played c3 she went with
Bishop d7 I went with 94 my idea was
simple your Bishop is here I'm putting
my knight here to take squares away from
your Bishop that simple she wins with
King d6 now I'm officially starting my
bluffing process Bishop e8 and finally
c5 which is again kind of again bluffing
bluffing stuff because if the King takes
check King d6 95 now do you think this
position is winning for white or do you
think black still is holding
we did all the things that we wanted we
got rid of the double pawn we took one
of the pawns from the Kings side instead
and we kept the pieces and the king is
closer to Center
yeah I think white is much better too
if Bishop b5 just keep the king in chill
position attack the King man just bring
the King to the Kings to the Queen side
or try and all right it was still kind
of tricky here for me because like I
knew I'm better I knew I should be like
getting my pieces out but I can't really
get it like if I play Knight g4 sorry if
I play 94 it's possible but what next
just King goes d6 and if I try to bring
the king it's still blocked
also there's be shot with one right now
if I try to bring the knight back when
am i trying to go like I couldn't find
any like the right square for the knight
so that's kind of why I decided to go
back to d1 and try the other side and I
finally got this chance to bring in the
King
be careful see for right now is a not
ideal because this take take take and
hiss King is way more active than yours
and this 3 to 2 is not winning it
suggests a draw so Bishop e5 King D to
King g5 now we just get c4 even if the
King didn't go to see it didn't go to e5
and like Bishop went to f1 so now a
question for you guys
why'd you move how can we stop this
threat or make the most out of it
yep 93 exactly just 93 attacking this
guy defending this guy cuz a fork and
yeah you guys got this alright so in the
game shipment King g5 c4 and after king
c3 I think she kind of gave up around
here because it didn't really make much
sense to continue and so this game
wasn't as bluffing as I honestly
remember to be I remembered that I
really suffered in the game cuz I
couldn't break through and it was an
interesting game for me because that
whole tournament the World Junior
Championship 2015 was a great tournament
for me I almost had metal and I kind of
slipped away and I ended up sixth fifth
sixth and it was still a good result
among girl under 20 it was 17 that's
good
I gained lots of rating and think one of
yeah that was really good turning 13
rounds really long but yeah anyways so
yeah it's it's a good idea that I kept
on fighting even though there's a lot of
chances that I just couldn't really
correct you and I'm hoping to show you
more games like this not just my games a
lot of other people's games that they
win by Bluff or they kind of have worse
positions and they end up with good
results and I'm hoping that it will both
encourage you to keep fighting and we'll
show you that no you do need a little
bit of walking chest alright I will see
you soon for the games of the week
[Applause]
you
[Music]
you